dann denkt sich mein gehirn abends ok
gestern hast du geschafft und 12 uhr
abends einzuschlafen heute schließlich
nicht vor drei dass ich weiß nicht woran
es liegt also jetzt bin ich gespannt
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video sollte ich hoffe
natürlich euch geht es gut wir haben
gerade schon ein bisschen später um
genau zu sein fünf nach zwölf morgen
ströme fahre ich für eine woche nach
berlin das heißt ich muss ein bisschen
was vor produzieren wo das ist natürlich
immer schwierig weil einige sagten mal
wieder nicht passen angekommen sind habe
ich mich heute gedacht ich wollte
sowieso ein video machen die coolsten
gadgets für dein zimmer
wir schauen uns heute mal ein paar
ansuchen dir aus werden die bestellen
und packen die dann im nächsten part
alles dieser maus also ein bisschen
schäme ich mich auch dafür den reaction
wieder auf meinem hauptkanal hochzuladen
weil reaction videos sind aufwand es
technisch schon ziemlich belebt aber an
der macht es ja auch von daher lehnt
euch zurück versuchen die neuesten
gadgets raus für dein zimmer und ich
würde sagen leute 1 was ich schon
bestellt habe was ihr euch unbedingt
kurz zeigen wollte ist dieses ding hier
was jetzt kommt passt auf das nächste
gadget ist ein absoluter hingucker
transport als ob es dein bluetooth
lautsprecher dadurch gleich gepolte
magnete in der luft schwebt durch einen
dynamischen stabilisierungsmechanismus
bleibt die lautsprecher kugel leute gebt
euch dass man das einfach eine musikbox
die schwebt in der luft wenn man sowas
in seinem zimmer hat oder sowas
überhaupt haben muss ja gar nicht
unbedingt fürs zimmer sein denn ja ich
habe so etwas noch nie gesehen habe ich
direkt bestellt ist leider noch nicht da
aber kommt auf jeden fall auch mit in
den parteien schauen wir weiter an einem
fleck in der luft und dreht sich um die
eigene achse und durch diese rotation
während der musikwiedergabe bekommt man
sogar ein 360° musik erlebnis geboten
außerdem kann die kugel auch als
eigenständiger bluetooth lautsprecher
ohne die basis verwendet werden
die unglaubliche musik box ist momentan
für 110 dollar erhältlich ich muss sogar
sagen ich habe die günstige erschossen
ich glaube sogar für nicht mal 60 euro
also da gibt es dann so ein fake von
oder keine ahnung also 110 euro dafür
ich bin wirklich mal gespannt was da
ankommt und ob das wirklich so in der
luft schwebt wie es da aussieht dann
würde ich sagen machen immer weiter was
kann
alex noch bestellen das erste geld
welches wir euch heute vorstellen wollen
ist ein bäcker von philips das besondere
an diesem becker ist seine
sonnenaufgangs simulation durch welche
man erholsamer aufwacht dies muss ich
direkt schon mal sagen mein zimmer ist
genau zur sonnenseite raus wenn da um 37
die sonne aufgeht es ist ich hab so zwar
jalousien aber die kann man nicht
richtig zu machen es ist bomben hell
also diese philips leid ich weiß nicht
gelingt indem der leucht dringend des
gadgets innerhalb der einzig minuten
langsam immer heller wird nach dem
besagten 30 minuten ist der gesamte raum
mit licht befüllt neben der visuellen
erscheinungen verfügt der wecker aber
noch über zwei integrierte weg töne und
eine radiofunktion genauso wie
herkömmliche wecker besitzt das philips
wake up light eine schlimmer funktion um
diese zu nutzen muss man lediglich die
oberseite des weckers berührt also ich
kann mir vorstellen wenn man ein zimmer
hat was ziemlich dunkel ist und es
schwierig hat morgens aufzustehen ist es
vielleicht ein geiles ding für mich ich
glaube das ist unnötig durch mars kippen
kurz als nächstes wollen wir euch das
unsichtbare bücherregal von umbra
vorstellen
durch dieses regal scheint es so als
würden ihre bücher in der luft schweben
ihr euch aber sicherlich schon
vorstellen könnt schweben die bücher
natürlich nicht tatsächlich in der luft
statt dessen ist das wandregal so
konzipiert dass es durch die bücher
verdeckt wird und somit unsichtbar wirkt
ich muss sagen ich bin jetzt kein bücher
fuchs ich habe ein paar bücher aber
lesen war noch nie was für mich auch
nicht in der schule keine ahnung
bisschen schade vielleicht auch meine
eltern lesen unfassbar gerne vielleicht
könnte ich denen das dann schenken aber
ich würde sagen dass bestelle ich auf
jeden fall mal um das zu testen geht ja
auch ganz schnell
also das wird bestellt immer weiter mit
dem nächsten gadget nachdem man das
bücherregal erfolgreich an der wand
montiert hat kann man anfangen bücher
darauf abzulegen jedoch ist es wichtig
dass es sich bei dem ersten buch mit
hardcover verhandelt der buchdeckel des
ersten buches durch kleine haken fixiert
wird
die kleinen haken sorgen dafür dass der
buchdeckel nicht herunter klappt die
schwebenden bücher sorgen für ein super
effekt und einen echten hingucker
zum thema das montagezubehör ist bereits
im lieferumfang enthalten
das ist ganz ganz wichtig also das muss
es auf jeden fall noch gesagt werden
ein hardcover-buch da brauche ich dann
noch oder habe ich so was ich weiß es
nicht aber das sieht schon ultra nice
aus vielleicht lasse ich das dann auch
so und schenkst nicht mal eltern
das nächste rennen wird wahrscheinlich
allen gamern unter euch gefallen
die rede ist vom gaming sitzsack von
gameware es bei diesem produkt handelt
es sich nämlich um einen sitzsack der ex
ich weiß nicht also ich sitze hier auch
seinen bequemen gaming stuhl brauche ich
einen sitzsack oder es gibt immer mal
weiter zum nächsten gadget das nächste
gadget für dein zimmer und trägt den
namen life xfx live
gerade bei illuminated live jetzt bin
ich mal gespannt
fx ley fix ist eine smarte led birne die
genauso einfach wie eine herkömmliche
glühbirne installiert werden kann
nach der installation kann man durch die
kostenlose live except die lichtfarben
der birne also app finde ich immer übels
nice ich habe auch schon so dinge
gesehen die wir an die wand pappen
kannst die können in 16 millionen
verschiedenen farben leuchten die du
über dein handy regulieren kannst sind
auch sehr teuer aber sowas ist ja
ähnlich
in sekundenschnelle wechseln neben dem
vorinstallierten farbkonzepte kann man
aber auch anhand eines bunten verbringst
seine eigene wunsch farbe wählen
nachdem man einige und hanna ist also
wenn das jetzt nicht 100 euro kostet
kauf ich das 59 eur 990 com neben war
mit ich verlinke euch die sache
natürlich auch alle in der video
beschreibung oder ihr bestellt sie hier
direkt bei top gadgets ein cooler kanal
schönen müsste der farbe gefunden hat
kann man diese dann in der app ein
speichern
die gespeicherten farbkonzepte kann man
anschließend mit der schnellzugriff
option immer sofort auswählen und
anwenden
darüber hinaus verfügt die smarte erlebt
ich habe schon so was ähnliches nie ihr
kennt das ja da hinten im hintergrund da
kannst du hier halt auch einfach die
farbe wechseln die kann ich euch
wirklich ans herz legen ultra geniale
led-lampe falls man das so nennt wenn
ich die amazon finde packe ich euch die
mal ganz oben wenn die beschreibung
kostet glaube ich 60 70 euro ich habe
die im baumarkt gekauft
man kann ja nie genug leds haben das
letzte zimmer gadget was wir euch heute
vorstellen wollen ist die mond lampe das
aussehen dieser nachtlicht lampe wurde
detailliert dem aussehen des echten
mondes nachempfunden als grund also
klingt schon mal eis ist auch meist aus
da kann vielleicht besser mit schlafen
wenn sonne mond lampe drin hat obwohl
vorsicht vollmond ich weiß nicht ist das
was lage für das design der lampe wurden
datenquellen aus nasa-satelliten
ausgewertet und verarbeitung h da
da wollte sie auf jeden fall ordentlich
mühe gegeben es entsteht eine originale
miniatur des echten mondes durch tippen
auf die oberfläche des mondes kann man
die lampe ein und ausschalten
ja ich weiß nicht ist halt auch wieder
eine lampe ich will eigentlich noch
andere sachen damit schon die led-lampe
bestellt das heißt wir gehen weiter zum
nächsten gadget und bestellen das dann
noch weil ich werde nicht nur lampen
auspacken in dem allerersten zimmer
gadgets video haben wir durch nano lief
rover vorne lief
das meinte ich eben das sind diese dinge
die man an die wand pub sind aber brutal
teuer
ich weiß nicht das sieht man was hat man
schon bei vielen gamern sicherlich
gesehen muss ich jetzt nicht unbedingt
ein stück von kaufen um euch das zu
zeigen da schaut euch lieber
irgendwelche gaming videos an
crippen war zum nächsten das nächste
budget welches wir euch vorstellen
wollen ist ein aquarium namens aqua farm
bei aqua pharmahandel habe ich das jetzt
richtig gesehen das ist ein aquarium mit
einem fisch drin gut das aquarium sind
immer fische drin und oben wachsen
pflanzen drauf was ist daran ist das
besondere und wie teuer ist dass es sich
um ein selbst rein liegendes glas
aquarium auf welchen pflanzen und
kräuter wachsen können dies funktioniert
wie folgt hat alter der fisch sorgt
dafür dass die pflanzen wachsen können
und im gegenzug reinigen die pflanzen
das wasser so entsteht ein eigenes
wie kann denn einen fisch dafür sorgen
dass pflanzen wachsen er bewegt sich im
wasser also die pflanzen würden doch
auch wachsen wenn der fisch nicht im
wasser wäre oder her also so ganz weil
ich das jetzt noch nicht
kleines ökosystem denn die exkremente er
fisch ausstößt im gegensatz zu werde ich
mal weiter hören sollen malen aquarien
nicht auf den boden gesammelt sondern
durch einen tunnel zu den pflanzen nach
oben gepumpt dort dienen die
abfallstoffe als natürliche düngung
mittel und fördern so das wachstum der
pflanzen
folglich zieht dieser prozesse also hier
muss ich sagen die idee übels lies wer
auch immer das entworfen hat ich glaube
die wunder hat gezeigt für so
naturliebhaber ist das doch das ding
oder ich hab nur ein bisschen
bauchschmerzen ich finde es super gerne
bestellen
allerdings bräuchten auch ein goldfisch
da drin und ich kenne mich da nicht
wirklich mit aus deswegen nachher stirbt
er mir dann aus versehen weg oder so
dann gibt's natürlich will ich nicht
oder leute wenn ihr sagt kauft das
unbedingt ich sehe dass wir anhand der
rezension vom video last man doch nach
oben da nicht nur das wachstum der
pflanzen sondern auch die reinigung des
wassers als konsequenz mit sich da das
fassungsvolumen mit 20 litern nicht
sonderlich groß ist empfehlen die
hersteller nur garnelen oder nano fische
in der aqua farm zu halten
ja gut garnelen die sind ja pflegeleicht
da kann man ja dann wirklich mal
überlegen und danach ab entschuldigung
nein nein natürlich nicht das markante
aquarium ist in den farben weiß und
schwarz erhältlich und wird mit einem
pflanzen aufsatz led beleuchtung und
einem insel geliefert
leute wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten
produkt das dritte gadget für dein
zimmer ist ein schlichter wecker in
holzwürfel optik
langweilig oder nicht wecker ich nehme
ein handy zu wecken nächstes nächste
gadget welches wir euch präsentieren
wollen ist der neue amazon eco show
welcher über ein hochauflösendes 10 zoll
hd display und hochwertigen dolby
lautsprechern verfügt ausserdem besitzt
finde ich auch nähen das letzte gadget
des heutigen videos wird allen gefallen
die probleme haben abends ein flop ja
ich hab's durchwaten probleme haben es
einzuschlafen
ihr glaubt es nicht mein schlaf rhythmus
ist immer so komisch alter manchmal
schaue ich es wirklich dann gehe ich
immer abends um 12 uhr ins bett steht
dann morgens um 8 uhr auf perfekt dann
denke ich mein gehirn abends ok gestern
hast du zwar geschafft und 12 uhr abends
einzuschlafen heute schließt nun nicht
vor drei dass ich weiß nicht woran es
liegt also jetzt bin ich gespannt warten
die einschlafhilfe namens togo
verspricht nämlich das erfolglose
startversuche endlich ein ende haben
werden die hersteller des gadgets
garantieren dass man mit hilfe von
bürgern 2,5 mal schneller einschlägt als
normalerweise
und wie funktioniert ist das kauf ich
mir das ist bis jetzt das leistet das
brauche auf jeden fall alles was man
dafür tun muss ist das gadget vor dem
schlafengehen einzuschalten und den dann
projektierten lichtkreis an der decke zu
beobachten
nun muss man seine atmung mit dem
lichtkreis synchronisieren aber wenn ich
den beobachte und meinen augen auf habe
wie solchen einschlafen meinen augen
sind doch auf nein die feier natürlich
dann irgendwann hoffe nicht automatisch
zu klappt das
wir werden es testen alter also da freue
ich mich drauf indem man einatmet wenn
das licht größer wird und ausatmet wenn
es kleiner wird diese methode führt
schließlich dazu dass man seine arten
züge von elf zu sechs atemzügen pro
minute reduziert dadurch wird ein
schneller gar und sanfte also es klingt
schon so für mich als wird es sinn
machen aber so ganz vertraut der sache
noch nicht leute das ist jetzt auch
bestellt wir haben auf jeden fall eine
menge coole sachen und falls ich noch
mehr finde bestelle ich das natürlich
auch noch freut euch auf jeden fall auf
das video wo ich das alles aus packe ich
weiß ob es das nächste oder über
nächstes video wird ansonsten hoffe es
hat euch gefallen ich habe es mal gerne
falls ihr reactions auch hier öfter
feiern würde würden wir natürlich sehr
gelegen kommen
ansonsten sehen bei uns am sonntag
wieder gibt es neues video dann wirst du
schon abonniert den kanal jacky letzten
- ab haut rein